man
if you
wait
if you are
hearing a lot about formula one because
of netflix and you're curious about it
start watching this season all right
that's my pitch to everybody
it's it's like it's like it's started
over
the cars are all new like all the rules
are new
so
you're just starting from scratch like
everyone else it's a good time to watch
and now there's going to be one in vegas
yeah yeah next thanksgiving yeah so
there's going to be three in the u.s
yeah and they're just probably just
going to add more right
or how many is how many are there
there's only three in america how many
races are there in general shoot i don't
actually know the number off top my head
i want to say it's like at least 20. and
how do they get the cars to america dude
the f1 logistics are insane really it's
like everything they ship like the teams
ship the entire garage
um
and you ship it like on container ships
or like it just depends i think they fly
it it just
uh i don't
some stuff i think they fly but
yeah it's wild how they can get all that
stuff safely from location location it
is absurd
but
it's an it's an interesting year you
know last year's ending was super
controversial
uh mercedes is not hot right now the new
rules have
[ __ ] them over so louis
he's uh
he finished 10th hamilton yeah lewis
hamilton yeah right yeah louis hamilton
yeah yeah
um
i was trying to think of like blew it
something
[Laughter]
blew it last weekend yeah
that's good did he did he blow it
uh
there's a lot to become i think he comes
he comes wherever yeah i think he he
definitely goes
he comes a lot of places
in the race
wherever he wants yeah in the race
she'll let him come wherever yeah
inside mostly yeah
yeah what did he place
he placed his semen on
i'll tell you what he blew last week and
that's for sure
now he he came in tenth and he hasn't
come in dude
yeah
dude you know it's hilarious
i think he hasn't been in 10th place
like finished the race in 10th place in
i can't even can't even hear you say it
so gross he i don't think he's done i
think the last time he finished 10th was
10 years ago
so when he uh
it was like [ __ ] up because there was
something with like
like uh a bunch of cars overheated so
he needed to pit but they were blocking
the pit lane and he opted not to it
seems like he didn't because he didn't
want to risk a penalty but whatever
people are arguing about whether or not
he [ __ ] that up
but
so he was in like fifth i think or fifth
or sixth and then uh yeah he finished
10th and he hasn't finished 10th i think
in 10 years so when he finished
uh his engineer was like ah sorry louis
that's p10 he goes is there even a point
for that like it was like it was like
does that mean like when diddy found a
one in his
stack of cash like it it was that didn't
even know tenth existed yeah literally
yeah he's like there's what do you mean
there's ten cars in this race yeah yeah
a lot there's ten what do you mean what
do you mean ten
tenth place what do you mean
yeah it's pretty there
that's close
oh god i need to get sucked off he
doesn't even have to do that he just uh
i love when he just like they'll be like
oh great race today lewis how you
feeling he just goes
you know first of all i want to thank
the fans
and then those you just hear
[Laughter]
he's looking at one
grown batty
no no it's grown men undoing their shirt
like sign my dad lois i love you
yeah yeah tenth that's [ __ ] crazy my
boy max
would never
um
yeah yeah he could never
um
yeah i mean yeah he was uh
his max's teammate started on first but
then
kark you know somebody crashed and then
uh the canadian one of the canadians
crashed and uh [ __ ] it all up so that
boy ended up fourth but max yeah he took
he took first first skull man
let's go man let's go do
skull mascot
so yeah dude i can't wait till i'm
watching
f1 and then just on the broadcast it's
just gonna panda you in the grass with
all that you're like scum out
the americans are really showing out
today scumma
a scum
[Laughter]
yeah dude yeah
what does he call his fans max
verstapenators
uh i think i think he calls them all
hoes no okay
no that's lewis yeah
no he's respectful
he that's the funniest [ __ ] is losers
not to say anything yeah right his
stories he just has to wink yeah
hey
yeah so did you was there's a duke game
this weekend that they won yeah saturday
by how many
by how many points points
yeah cause you know basketball and the
ball goes in the
and that's a point yeah yeah uh i was
like it was it was pretty sizable i want
to say like seven points that's pretty
nine what everything's pretty small
college basketball oh you're just saying
seven in general is small
yeah exactly
um
no it was a great it was a great game
we won i'm stoked and now unc won
against saint pete's or whatever the
[ __ ] that school is yeah
um
first time ever a 15 seed has ever made
it to the elite eight which is pretty
[ __ ] crazy but then unc just smoked
them was the 15th seed
st pete's oh the school oh got it guys
is there st peters saint pete's can you
look that up
it's i think he's in new jersey st
pete's
right st peters say peters
what
mascot is the peacocks yeah the peacocks
and they won on national peacock day
isn't that weird well which i didn't i
don't know that was a thing why would
that be a thing yeah did the pickup
artists make up
yeah it's just we go to the club and
giant top hats yeah yeah crazy ass like
pink furry
coats peacock yeah hey
what's up ladies
so
that's cool that's cool that you guys
won
yeah we won and unc won so now we play
you did good out there thank you yeah
thank you
no i'm just i'm stoked man it's gonna be
good the next game's on saturday and
then you're gonna lose
uh no
[Laughter]
stop saying that i don't need that
energy we're gonna win
i'm pretty sure
unc
put duke like in a casket and then
paraded it around town then everyone
took a turn peeing on it
and then those pictures on it yeah jesus
christ
yeah
i'm pretty sure they um
the town collectively took a [ __ ] in a
in a gigantic trash bag and mailed it to
coach dukes
and we're like coach duke is that we
just called him yeah coach duke
that's
why not at this point coach duke
tim apple yeah yeah and then uh they
[Laughter]
and they said eat up bud yeah cause uh
that's what that's all you're gonna be
eating in the final jesus christ yeah no
we're gonna win it's gonna be awesome
yeah no for sure and i'm looking forward
to it yeah